estos médicos prácticamente no tienen
tiempo para descansar trabajan en turnos
de 12 horas en un hospital militar en la
región de donges pero si hay casos
urgentes se quedan más tiempo recorren
los estrechos pasillos para evaluar a
los soldados heridos en los combates y
tratan sus lesiones
una labor ya habitual para andrew un
médico voluntario
y apóstolos sudor embotellado
sólo hago mi trabajo todos hacemos lo
necesario sólo cumplimos con nuestro
deber lo único importante es que hay una
persona que hace este trabajo pero estos
médicos no solo se enfrentan a la ardua
tarea de intentar mantener con vida a
sus pacientes también velan por su salud
mental y es que muchos sufren las
secuelas irreversibles de la guerra son
los momentos más difíciles son los
psicológicos cuando te llegan chicos de
20 o 22 años jóvenes y tienen lesiones
graves cuando pierden las extremidades o
la vista cuando quedan discapacitados
un dijo ser las fuerzas rusas están
empecinadas en controlar la región de
donges capturaron prácticamente toda la
región de luhansk en junio las intensas
batallas que mataron a miles de personas
de ambos bandos la fuerte resistencia
del ejército ucraniano sorprendió a
moscú